okay so I mentioned this before the
break let's get now to the full
embarrassment that was Donald Trump's
acting chief of staff Mick Mulvaney on
Fox News Sunday with Chris Wallace
yesterday this will be something
different we're gonna look in detail at
an interview and there is so much to
learn from this interview that Chris
Wallace did with Trump's acting chief of
staff Mick Mulvaney I already played for
you the short clip in another story of
Mick Mulvaney claiming that even though
Donald Trump is the President of the
United States that that's just one of
his gigs effectively that Trump still
considers himself to be in the
hospitality industry so we won't go back
over that that's ridiculous enough what
was actually far more embarrassing was
the way in which Mick Mulvaney came
completely unglued trying to deny
directly to Chris Wallace's face having
said things that are on video which
Chris Wallace was prepared for and threw
right back at min Mick Mulvaney nice
face with clips and it is glorious now
you don't often see this in media in the
United States in general and when you do
it's not usually on fox news but i am i
believe that we are in such a desperate
circumstance when it comes to proper
preparation by an interviewer for
interviewing someone that you believe is
likely to be deceptive and to be ready
not only with video clips but with facts
and quotes and the demeanor to actually
question it that this is what we have
and i want to go through it with you
we're gonna look at a bunch of this in
pieces because not only is the subject
matter important but it's good to be
able to parse it it's good to be able to
understand how chris wallace structured
it and there's a lot to be learned from
this and the other thing to keep in mind
is this is much more common in british
news media this is much more common in i
watch a lot of argentinian news this is
much more common in argentinian media
where in the US very often with people
in positions of power once they give you
the same non answer or lie two or three
times you just move on and it's a
combination of not wanting to push the
interview in a way where you are at risk
of maybe losing access to the person or
an administration combined with the time
constraints of corporate media Chris
Wallace does not let it go and you
actually expose Mick Mulvaney as the
absolutely immoral Trump brown-noser
that he is willing to just tell lie
after lie after lie let's look at the
first clip alright let's have the
conversation yeah why here's my first
question why did you say in that
briefing that President Trump had
ordered a quid PO crow quid pro quo that
investigating the Democrats that that a
to Ukraine depended on investigating the
Democrats why'd you say that getting
aside what I said that's what people
said that I said here's what I said I'll
say it again and hopefully people will
listen this time there were two reasons
that we held up the aid we've talked
about this at some length the first one
was the the rampant corruption in
Ukraine Ukraine by the way Chris is so
bad in Ukraine that in 2014 Congress
passed a law making it making us
requiring us to make sure that
corruption was moving in the right
direction so corruption is a big deal
everybody knows it the president was
also concerned about whether or not
other nations specifically European
nations were helping with foreign aid to
the Ukraine as well we've talked about
that for quite a while now I did then
mention that in the past the president
had mentioned for me to time to time
about the DNC server he'd mentioned the
DNC server to other people publicly he
even mentioned it to President Solinsky
in the phone call but it wasn't
connected to the aide and that's where I
think people got sidetracked this
weekend at that press conference but two
reasons for holding back the aid of it
let me pursue that that sir because I
believe that anyone listening to what
you said in that briefing could come to
only one conclusion let's play what you
said sir that he also mentioned to me
and past that the the the corruption
related to the DNC server absolutely no
question about that but that's it that's
why we held up the money you just
described is a quid pro quo it is
funding will not flow
the investigation into the Democratic
server happened as well we do we do that
all the time
with foreign policy he mentioned the
corruption and that's why we held up the
money and we do it all the time with
foreign policy all the time we withhold
aid for things like this is what Mick
Mulvaney
is saying so Chris Wallace comes back
after Mulvaney tries to filibuster for a
little while and says yeah but hold on
Mick what about the video where you said
it and mauvais me immediately starts to
come apart you were asked specifically
by Jonathan Karl was investigating
Democrats one of the conditions for
holding up the aid was that part of the
quid pro quo and you said it happens all
the time
go back and watch what I said before
that I don't think eyes can cue it up
and it was a long answer about
corruption and a long view totally like
I told you then and then I said exactly
the same thing I just said now so he
starts to just do double speak and a
minute later after again filibustering
chris wallace wallace goes back at him
with more clips which he has prepared
another moment where Mick Mulvaney said
exactly the thing Chris Wallace is
accusing him of having said despite
Mulvaney attempting to deny it to Chris
Wallace's face and you know I hate to go
through this but but you said what you
said and the fact is after that exchange
with Jonathan Karl you were asked
another time why the aid was held up
what was the condition for the aid and
you didn't mention two conditions you
mentioned three conditions and I want to
and let's listen to all three of them
cuz you stated it very clearly let's
listen three issues for that the
corruption in the country whether or not
other countries were participating the
support of the Ukraine and whether or
not they were cooperating in an ongoing
investigation with our Department of
Justice that's completely legitimate not
only did you say that investigating the
Democrats was one of the three
conditions not to that you had just said
that you had talked about investigating
the Democrats was
part of the quid pro quo you also said
if I may it was part of the Justice
Department investigation into the
origins of the Russia probe but so
Wallis keeps going and to his credit
these officials count on that if you
tell the same lie over and over again to
corporate media eventually the
interviewer is going to move on either
because they don't want to get in
trouble with the administration or they
want to save face or they're pressed for
time or whatever the case may be but
Chris Wallace is not moving on each time
Mick Mulvaney looks like more of a liar
which he is look to the facts on the
ground thinks that you can actually sort
of certify and what should put this
issue to bed is that the money flowed
without any connection whatsoever to the
dance I serve you in your first episode
which I gave you so that's why we held
up the money first you just said here
that it was for two reasons now you're
acknowledging it was for three reasons
if you held up the money for three
reasons
that was that's a quid pro quo they've
gotta satisfy on us on those now maybe
the president backed off that but that
was the proposition here I'm not
acknowledging this through his
resilience let's go back that's we go
back to the I recognize that go back to
what actually happened in the real world
I love that you really have to be
careful with these guys because they
have media training Mick Mulvaney knows
at least in terms of demeanor and
verbosity how to talk to corporate media
and to come away sounding like he makes
sense even though he's saying a and then
the opposite of a Mulvaney says I never
said that there were three reasons and
Wallace says well you did I played it
for you and Mulvaney says I acknowledge
that if you're a casual viewer you're
hearing Mick Mulvaney in a 60 second
clip deny that he said there were three
reasons for the aid being withheld and
also say I acknowledge that is he saying
that he acknowledges having said it but
he misspoke is he saying he acknowledges
that actually there were three reasons
even though he's out of the other side
of his mouth telling you that there were
not actually three reasons what does it
mean it's confusing what it means is
that he's a liar of course
then Mulvaney gets to the disastrous
phone call transcript which of course
was not a transcript it was a few
plucked paragraphs from the transcript
which was released Trump released it
thought it made him look great
it actually was an incriminating
transcript in reality just a truncated
summation of the call excerpts of the
call and now it really starts to go bad
for Mick Mulvaney because Chris Wallace
was prepared for the phone call
discussion in the briefing you flatly
denied any connection between holding up
the aid and investigating Joe Biden and
his son right correct okay in his phone
call with President zolensky however
President Trump specifically meant mr.
Biden's do me a favor
front lawyer Rudy Giuliani pushed all
summer for Ukraine to announce it was
investigating Purisima the company that
paid hunter Biden and a former NSC
official testified this week before
Congress john bolton was so disturbed by
the way you were directing people to
work with rudy giuliani he said quote i
am not part of whatever drug deal he was
speaking metaphorically of whatever drug
feels sundaland a US diplomat and
Mulvaney are cooking up no question you
were following the president's orders
but your fingerprints are all over
linking aid to Ukraine with
investigating the Biden's ok no that's
not true let's go I'll take one of those
at a time which is the Bolton thing
because I read that and I was surprised
because John Bolton never complained to
me about it know what at NS C ever
complained to me about anything that was
going on I I didn't see sunland's
testimony this week because none of us
have seen Shauna's testimony which is
another story entirely I did get a
chance to read his opening statement
when he said that Bolton never
complained to him Fiona Hill never got a
chance to complain to him I think you
need to put sort of that if you wait a
minute Fiona Hill is the one who
testified that's the quote came from
never complained to solid about what was
happening when it was handled she
complained to her boss John Bolton who
did what who said he told her to go
immediately to a lawyer right at the NSC
and to complain about works for John
Bolton yet John Bolton didn't go say
anything to anybody doesn't that raise a
red flag
but let's go back to the first when you
talk about which is the president's
phone call because at the end of the day
that's what this is really about right
that's why we are here well this I don't
know about that I don't agree on this
was mixed Comiskey mischaracterized this
is another technique okay understand
that this is a technique that officials
under pressure will often use it's a
sort of Gish gallop we're instead of
answering the crux of the question
instead of getting to the heart of the
matter
they give four different pseudo
rebuttals two minor points that don't
actually refute the substance of what it
is that's being discussed but it appears
to the untrained by that I mean not in a
pejorative way to just casual news
viewers who have lives and go to work
and take care of their kids it appears
as though Mick Mulvaney has refuted the
narrative that Chris Wallace has
presented when in reality he has the big
picture is Mulvaney as an obvious liar
he's trying to suck up to trump until
Trump turns on him because Mulvaney will
be ridiculed in the same way that
Giuliani for a while was pulled off the
air because it became too embarrassing
mauvais knee now has been very publicly
doing lots of interviews in the wake of
the Ukraine Fiasco he may end up getting
pulled Chris Wallace was well prepared
here Chris Wallace was prepared with
clips and with knowledge and with quotes
and he does something that I try to do
when I interview public officials when I
interview a scientist I go in with my
questions prepared to learn I want to
learn from the scientist when I
interview an elected official I want to
go in anticipating what their answers
are going to be to my questions and how
they may attempt to either distort or
not answer and that's exactly what Chris
Wallace did here and as prepared as
Chris Wallace is still when someone like
Mulvaney comes in prepared to filibuster
ready to question minor points in a gif
calleb format even an experienced
interviewer like Chris Wallace can get
thrown off track in the moment and
that's something that unless you're
doing interviews like this can be
difficult to understand how it happens
but overall very solid Mulvaney
looking like the dishonest Trump
brown-noser that he is and we'll be
posting clips from this interview on our
Instagram page as well I hope you'll
follow us there at David Pakman on
Instagram while you're in your Instagram
app give me a follow as well at david
pakman.com in The Washington Post these
are two of the most important
investigative media outlets in the Trump
era and because Donald Trump doesn't
like them he is now saying he will be
terminating their White House press
credentials now one of the things that
has it was going to be a focus actually
of my keynote address at the grassroots
radio conference in Rochester New York a
couple of weeks ago unfortunately that
event had to be cancelled because I
ended up in the hospital with an
emergency appendectomy and I was not
able to give this talk but I was going
to focus on the strength of the attacks
on media under the current
administration we've seen this concerted
authoritarian disdain towards the media
everything from threatening libel
lawsuits to proposing journalism
licenses to talking about shutting down
media outlets and should certain media
outlets even be allowed to exist which
is a very authoritarian concept even
rising to the level of going after
targeting attacking individual
journalists some of whom have actually
as a result of being targeted by Donald
Trump in the administration been the
target of physical violence at events
and Trump rallies and now Donald Trump
in a total Gong Show interview that ran
an hour with his buddy Sean Hannity on
Fox News last night is saying that his
administration will be terminating the
press credentials of the New York Times
and The Washington Post let's take a
look at it Sean Hannity of course just
gushing and thrilled hell it might even
have been Sean Hannity's idea that
Donald Trump do this we know that
Hannity frequently talks to Donald Trump
before Trump goes to bed extraordinarily
romantic isn't it let's take a look
option that something has to be
investigated that's what you have to
look but I watch this crazy Anderson
Cooper the other day during the debate
apologize for having to ask the question
to them apologist if
or me he declared innocence if that were
my sons that took 168 thousand dollars
from this very questionable company an
energy company and they knew nothing
about energy you know he knew nothing
about energy and he has a bad record bad
track record including getting thrown
out of the Navy and even the way he got
into Navy is interesting in his position
if that were Don Jr if that were Eric
Trump were very outstanding young men it
would be the biggest story of the
century what does it say about the media
I agree leave the media is corrupt
not all media's look I know some some
great people including you but I know
some great journalists look I think a
Pulitzer Prizes to people they got it
wrong okay all these people Fortuna from
the New York Times which is a fake
newspaper we don't even want it in the
White House anymore gonna probably
terminate that in The Washington Post if
fake but you take a look at the New York
Times and you take a look at the kind of
reporting they do it was all it turned
out to be all wrong now you can probably
guess that everything Trump said there
is a lie but I want to focus in
specifically on the media attacks you
know he talks about crazy Anderson
Cooper again another example of
targeting specific journalists he throws
hunter Biden under the bus I thought
that the children of elected officials
were off-limits but then it's the big
media attack the corrupt media we need
to terminate the New York Times and The
Washington Post now I don't believe that
he is saying he needs to terminate them
as entities although he's eluded to
shutting down media outlets in the past
it's pretty clear that what he means is
terminating their access to White House
press briefings which by the way there
hasn't been one for nine months and you
know traveling with the president and
this type of thing this is how tyranny
slowly starts to rain this is how
authoritarianism develops and the
pro-gun people always talk about we need
our handguns and rifles to protect
ourselves from a government that becomes
tyrannical that may use tanks or
whatever else
in the modern era purported ostensible
democracies like the United States they
rarely become authoritarian or
tyrannical to borrow the word that the
right-wing gun people like to use in
this cartoonish tanks on the street way
although Trump has talked about wanting
a parade with tanks they tend to become
more quietly tyrannical by attacking
press freedom by limiting the access of
media outlets that they don't like by
turning public opinion against
individual journalists and I don't see a
single one of them saying we've got to
defend freedom of the press with those
firearms yes a pre Free Press when the
president likes what the press is saying
and you will hear the defense that hold
on a second David he's not shutting down
the New York Times he's not shutting
down the Washington Post they are just
merely going to lose their White House
credentials we are experiencing such
scandal fatigue that I don't believe we
are understanding the gravity of what
Donald Trump is promising to do here in
his interview with Sean Hannity there
are times in American history where a
president specifically targeting the
press credentials of individual media
outlets that they don't like would be
considered impeach able but due to
scandal fatigue due to the dense
desensitization that we have experienced
as a result of the outrageous acts of
this administration this is an
authoritarian nightmare that is going
wholly unnoticed and it is being backed
implicitly and or explicitly by the
Republican Senate which is another issue
that we've been talking about which I
won't divert into today and much like
with the ignored impeachment subpoenas
that I talked about earlier in today's
program there is ZERO indication there
is no indication that this is going to
have consequences unless and this is why
I keep talking about it and I actually
got some emails this week saying David
doesn't matter that you're repeating
yourself like a broken record you need
to keep talking about this there may be
no consequences to any of this unless we
mode vote him out in November of 2020
it's barely 12 months away because
they're ignoring the subpoenas and
getting away with it they are going
after media
listen getting away with it they are
terminating press credentials and
getting away with it and there may be
the only hope of voting this out in
November of 2020 every time we talk
about how X or Y scenario is likely to
go forward during what is hopefully the
last 15 months of Donald Trump's
presidency those analyses assume that
Republicans are not going to turn on
Donald Trump that in the end Republican
senators would not vote to impeach
Donald Trump that Trump's Republican
cabinet would not use the 25th amendment
to try to remove Trump from power those
are the assumptions that were operating
under however former Trump White House
communications director I think he
lasted 10 days Anthony scaramouche II
has a different perspective he now says
that 20 or more Republicans are set to
turn on Donald Trump
this is scaramouche II effectively
predicting a sort of Nixon like scenario
from the 1970s you might remember
Republicans a went to Nixon in the 70s
in the wake of in the in the midst of
the Watergate fiasco and said listen we
don't want to impeach you but we're
going to have to if it comes to a vote
so why don't you resign and that's
exactly what Richard Nixon did check out
scaramouche II on CNN making the case
well you know he obviously knows a lot
more facts about the case or gonna
unfold over the next you know two to six
weeks Don and so I think that's got him
rattled and I think he's also looking at
the future who does not look good for
him because as more facts unfold about
Syria as more facts unfold about the
people that have been arrested recently
and the conjoin Minh of all those issues
over there it's going to be devastating
for the president and what will
ultimately happen which I predicted on
CNN's air two months ago the full-blown
meltdown were experiencing speaker
Pelosi described it today but well
eventually will eventually happen is the
criminal activity will be so great that
the GOP and there'll be 20 plus senators
will say okay I can't take this anymore
reminiscent to what Howard Baker and
Barry Goldwater did in the 70s and
called Richard Nixon and said look No
Mas you got to go and so that that will
eventually happen and that's
reason why he's pressurized but I really
wish the White House press would just
ask him what was in it for him
personally so this is just one guy right
I mean this is just Anthony scaramouche
you never want to put too much stock
into what any one person says but this
is a narrative that has been floating
around for a while and the idea is
actually deeper than 20 Republicans will
turn on Trump the real idea is a whole
bunch of Republicans have already turned
on Trump in their minds internally the
question is that they are balancing
their own political futures with doing
what they believe is right which is
turning on Donald Trump now this isn't a
great moral realization about
Republicans Republicans who support
Trump are immoral and indifferent to
supporting so-called conservative values
that's bad enough Republicans who
privately don't support Trump but
continue to support them publicly
they are also terrible they're merely
choosing political expediency in
calculation for the benefit of their
careers over what they actually believe
would be good for the country which is
pretty damn bad in a different way so
when we hear scaramouche's say it he may
know what he's talking about
he may not it'll be interesting to see
if and when it happens but to the extent
that this is an existing narrative that
we've been following
we just need to watch the polls support
for impeachment and removal has been
climbing if we believe that there are at
least some disgruntled Republican
senators out of the 53 that are
currently in the Senate and they're
waiting around for public support to be
high enough that the risk to their
careers is diminished if they come out
and say it is time to remove Donald
Trump we're pretty damn close to getting
there we have support for impeachment
and removal hitting and surpassing 50%
in a hyperpolarized modern status quo of
American politics you're not going to
get that much more before it becomes
tantamount to major support for removing
the President of the United States from
office and what we know is that these
Republican senators are all about just
putting their finger to the wind trying
to end up on the right side of public
opinion
conservative so-called values be damned
so we don't even have to put any special
stock in what Anthony scaramouche E is
saying here this has been a possibility
for a while we've been considering it
for about a year and a half and we'll
follow it there's a timing issue though
as we are now only 12 and a half months
from the 2020 election which is if
Republicans are going to turn on Trump
they sort of need to do it pretty soon
before it's going to be too little too
late all right we have gotten to the
point where the President of the United
States in what is obviously a desperate
and crazed sort of last-ditch effort to
try to make the case that he's not
obviously violating the emoluments
Clause of the Constitution is now
calling the emoluments clause to the
Constitution in and of itself phony
that's his word not mine now as you may
know Donald Trump has endlessly been
clearly violating the emoluments clause
I will redefine what that causes for you
momentarily just so we're all on the
same page the strategy from Trump
estudia monuments clause that has mostly
failed since he's so obviously and
brazenly continuing to violate the
emoluments clause to the Constitution
then they shifted to pretending that the
emoluments clause to the Constitution is
part of the Constitution but not really
like it's sort of this appendage to the
Constitution it's an irrelevant vestige
of sorts it doesn't really matter of
course that's also not true either we
value the Constitution or we don't
either the value of the Constitution is
complete or it is not and you can't pick
and choose when it is and is not worthy
or deserved of being adhered to and now
Donald Trump is straight up saying
including to his supposedly
constitutional conservative followers
that the emoluments clause is phony
Trump spoke to the media yesterday
including about trying to have the g7 at
his personal club Doral a plan which has
since been cancelled by the way because
it also would be an obvious violation of
the emoluments clause to the
Constitution
Trump was asked about it and he said you
people with this phony emoluments clause
other presidents if you love other
process were wealthy not huge wealth
George Washington was actually
considered a very very rich man at the
time but they were in their businesses
George Washington they say had two desks
he had a presidential desk and a
business desk I don't think you people
with this phony of monuments laws and by
the way I would say that it's cost me
anywhere from two to five billion
dollars to be president and that's okay
between what I lose and what I could
have made you'll notice there Donald
Trump also defending a president being
president and running a business while
being president of the United States and
in so doing casually equating himself to
George Washington it's it's interesting
that there are so many other crazy
things that he says in that 31 second
clip that equating himself to George
Washington is not even the primary thing
that we are talking about like that
that's how outrageous the status quo is
it's time for a reality check the
emoluments clause is the constitution
it's article 1 section 9 and it says no
title of nobility shall be granted by
the United States and no person holding
any office of profit and trust under
them shall without the consent of
Congress except of any present emolument
office or title of any kind whatever
from any King prince or foreign state
that's the Constitution of the United
States article 1 section 9 it's not the
only relevant emoluments related portion
of the Constitution we also have Article
2 section 1 which says the President
shall at stated times receive for his
services a compensation which shall
neither be increased nor diminished
during the period for which he shall
have been elected and he shall not
receive within that period any other
emolument from the United States or any
of them so what do the constitutional
conservatives say about this Trump meant
phony as a metaphor maybe I don't know I
haven't heard any defenses
because I think increasingly the
constitutional conservatives are
pretending that they never really wanted
Trump to be President anyway and Oh what
me vote for Trump no I don't remember
what I did in November of 2016 if there
is one thing that won't be able to be
said once this nightmare is over and
hopefully that nightmare is over in 15
months although it could be four years
and 15 months we will not be able to say
that people simply had no idea what
Donald Trump was doing because he's
telling us he's saying that running a
business while being president is fine
he's telling us that he sees
inconvenient parts of the Constitution
as phony this is actually once again
impeachable what what i mean by that is
violating the emoluments clause
endlessly that is impeachable and that's
been going on for two and a half years
however long it's been at this point the
publicly calling of the emoluments
clause phony is also in and of itself
impeachable because donald trump swore
an oath to uphold the constitution and
he's publicly saying that there's a
piece of the constitution which he swore
to uphold on a Bible remember he's
saying well there's a part of that
Constitution that not only am I not
going to uphold in my mind it's phony
that is impeachable publicly admitting
to the dereliction of the oath that he
swore to uphold you can forget if you
want about the first two and a half
years of the donald trump presidency
merely based on the last seven days
alone Donald Trump is impeachable it's
not clear there are going to be any
consequences and the next thing I want
to talk about won't we listen if we're
going to talk about consequences we have
to talk about legally issued subpoenas
by a co-equal branch of government as
enshrined by the Constitution and the
rule of law which the Trump
administration is ignoring and that's
where we need to go next so there is
devastating just devastating new
evidence in the Trump Ukraine quid pro
quo fiasco and it is really important to
stand what we mean by evidence and I
think this is really worth doing so I'm
gonna focus on that element today and I
hope that this is useful there is new
testimony under oath from the United
States envoy to the Ukraine who says
that listen the story we've been getting
publicly is true Donald Trump indeed
made the security aid hundreds of
millions of dollars in security aid to
Ukraine contingent on dependent upon
Ukraine publicly saying that they were
going to carry out this politically
motivated smear investigation against
Joe and hunter Biden that is as a fact
not very surprising to people in my
audience I presume who have been
following the story but this is the
really important part that I want to
focus on today if we go back to the
Russia probe and carry through to what
is going on now with Ukraine and the
impeachment inquiry the Trump is right
has insisted time and time again that
there is no evidence that everything
that there is in the Trump Russia probe
with the Ukraine Fiasco it is hearsay
and people's baseless allegations and
this is why we have to be just super
crystal clear here because unless we are
prepared to address this farcical claim
they're going to get away with it okay
testimony under oath is evidence now
there is a difference between evidence
and sort of caught red-handed
irrefutable proof but before we even get
to that we have to understand how they
are distorting what actually counts as
evidence and before I go into this let
me give you an analogy which i think is
useful here consider the word theory
okay the word theory has one meaning in
colloquial usage and it has another
meaning in the world of science in
science when the when the term theory is
used we're talking about a group of
propositions that explain facts or
explain some real-world phenomena for
example the theory of evolution that is
a very specific meaning in the world of
science but the word theory in popular
culture in colloquial usage has a
different meaning and theory in
colloquial usage often actually means
what in
is called a hypothesis which is it's
sort of like a starting point or it's a
possibility is one of many possibilities
for explaining something in the real
world and one of the things that the
American right-wing loves to do is for
example in the context of climate change
deliberately miss state or flip between
definitions of what they mean by theory
they'll just deliberately distort the
definition of theory by switching back
and forth between the scientific
definition and the colloquial usage
which really means hypothesis they'll
say you know a theory about climate
change a theory is just one of twenty
thirty or forty different explanations
about what's going on we'll hold on a
second that may be what it means in
colloquial usage but when science call
something a theory it has a different
meaning now let's go back to this
evidence thing bearing in mind this
analogy from you know theory hypothesis
all along Republicans have said there is
no evidence for anything in the Russia
probe there is no evidence of any quid
pro quo in the Ukraine Fiasco sometimes
they'll also use the word hearsay
they'll say it's all hearsay what they
mean is no one has been caught on video
in a cartoonish out of the movies sort
of red-handed way that satisfies them as
irrefutable proof but here's the really
important thing sworn testimony is
evidence William Taylor the United
States envoy to Ukraine provided sworn
testimony to lawmakers where he says
there is no question that Donald Trump
was withholding aid in order to try to
get Ukraine to smear Joe Biden and
hunter Biden publicly so now the
trumpets are coming in and they're
saying hold on a second what William
Taylor says is not evidence it's merely
hearsay which is also the wrong word but
let's forget that for now we're not
gonna get into hearsay right now sworn
testimony is evidence sworn testimony is
evidence made under oath or affirmation
under penalty of perjury now someone
could give sworn testimony and be lying
someone could give sworn testimony and
not remember the facts correctly but
when the right
says there is no evidence that's either
a lie or an ignorant understanding of
what evidence means the testimony is
evidence but here's where the theory vs.
hypothesis thing comes back to be useful
they're also using evidence
interchangeably with proof this is the
other game that they're playing William
Taylor giving evidence that Donald Trump
withheld aid in a quid pro quo for Joe
Biden to be smeared is not irrefutable
proof that that took place and that's
okay but what they are often saying when
they say there is no evidence is that it
is not a refutable proof which is a
completely different standard it's a
completely different issue
so now understanding this all of this
relates to the total and complete lack
of critical thinking and epistemology
skills in our society
which I've been sounding the alarm about
for years at this point when people
understand how arguments are made when
people understand how to figure out for
themselves if the words being used to
describe things are the most accurate
and precise words that could be used you
can't trick people like this the climate
change theory hypothesis games the games
around what counts as evidence versus
proof you can only get traction with
distortions and lies you can only
confuse people semantically when people
don't have the skills to think these
things through for themselves and that's
really the tragedy that's really the
saddest thing of all about the status
quo of American just ability to think
critically
now some last thoughts about the
substance of the testimony from William
Taylor the US envoy to Ukraine just to
kind of come full circle and do at least
some small analysis of that although it
doesn't really warrant much of an
analysis because we know what's going on
number one the testimony is truly
devastating to the Trump narrative
because everyone involved who has given
testimony including testimony about
their knowledge of that Trump phone call
with the Ukrainian president even Mick
Mulvaney without realizing it without
meaning to everyone is confirming
elements of the story that the aid was
contingent upon the smears of Joe Biden
now after the fact they all did not
they'll try to go back and again play
semantic games about the definitions of
the words that they used but that is the
trend
everybody's confirming the original
story even if they don't mean to
secondly this also seems to have
jump-started Fox News back into state
media mode where you know we've talked
about there have been recently some
disagreements between Fox News and
Donald Trump on some minor issues the
last 24 hours the testimony from William
Taylor has completely restarted Fox
News's narrative around the entire
Ukraine thing is a nothing burger it's
all a smear attempt against Donald Trump
it's all a witch-hunt etc they covered
this story about William Taylor's
testimony as if the testimony from
William Taylor is obviously not credible
and suggests that the Trump witch-hunt
narrative is the correct one which I
mean imagine being that disconnected
from reality that that's your takeaway
and again to go back to the conversation
between Donald Trump and the Ukrainian
president the excerpt that was released
they initially said it was a transcript
then they said well it's not a
transcript it's it's a summation in
reality it was a partial transcript
Trump released that believing that it
vindicated him
anyone who again can think for
themselves can apply basic critical
thinking and epistemology skills to a
document and not be swayed by the story
that Donald Trump tells you about it you
realize that that partial transcript is
extraordinarily damning when it comes to
Donald Trump's involvement in this quid
pro quo we will see what the future is
of this entire thing I know that there
are people in the audience who from a
practical perspective are saying listen
David I know you're right and it's not
just you that's saying I mean it's
anybody who analyzes the evidence
understands what it is that took place
here but it is going to be hard to get
Trump on it and I don't disagree with
you and that's why all of these
investigations all of these discussions
they need to be properly contextualized
in let's use them to motivate voters to
go out and vote for someone other than
Donald Trump because the most likely
scenario I know that there are other
paths the most likely scenario is none
of this stuff will force
fully removed Trump from office but if
we play it correctly if we talk about it
in the right way it will motivate voters
to go out on November of whatever the
data is early November 2020 and say no
more I'm voting for somebody else let me
know what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show okay I've got to start today
by revising a previous analysis that
I've made I now believe that it is
possible possible but it is still going
to be an uphill battle for Democrats to
take control of the Senate in 2020
really good post about this on our
subreddit from user homie Alex 7 and
homie Alex is completely right the
reality has changed so our analysis has
to change so if you've heard me talk
about this previously I've said that
there is a very real chance of removing
Donald Trump from the White House in
2020 that's the presidential election
that in the House of Representatives
where Democrats currently have control
there is a very real chance that
Democrats could extend their majority
above and beyond where it is now but I
said that when you look at the Senate
and you look at the seats that are up
for re-election in 2020 that it didn't
seem plausible that Democrats could take
control of the Senate and really we'd be
looking at 2022 is the first serious
opportunity where Democrats could take
control of the Senate but the good news
if you want Democrats to take control is
that there are now some specific races
that have changed where it is still an
uphill battle but Democrats can take
control of the Senate in 2020 so we're
gonna get into exactly what races these
are and we'll do the analysis and then
really after we do the case-by-case the
the race by race analysis as it may be
it'll be important to do sort of a more
overarching step back look at it because
a lot of times it's not about individual
races it's about the general way that
the the election will go so quickly
catching up there are 100 seats in the
Senate - per state there are six-year
terms in the Senate every two years
about a third of those hundred seats are
up for election
November Class two they have classes one
two and three splitting the hundred
seats up into three classes class two is
up for re-election that's thirty three
seats and then in addition to those
thirty three seats there are two special
elections one is in Arizona to fill the
vacancy left by the death of Republican
Senator John McCain there is also a
special election in Georgia because
senator Johnny Isakson who's also a
Republican is resigning at the end of
this year so of the total 35 seats that
are up in 2020 Republicans have 23 seats
to defend and Democrats have 12 seats to
defend many of the Democratic seats are
safe for Democrats Massachusetts for
example Oregon is another one many of
the Republican seats are equally safe
for Republicans like Louisiana and
Montana for example but the balance of
power often ends up depending on a small
number of races and there is now a path
that is not an outrageous one for
Democrats to take the Senate so right
now the hundred and sixteenth Congress
Republicans of 53 seats Democrats have
45 plus two independents that tend to
caucus with them it's Bernie Sanders and
I believe it's angus King 53 to 47
effectively Democrats needing fournette
seats to take over control putting them
at 51 and Republicans at 49 the other
scenario is that if Democrats take the
White House the vice president becomes
the tie-breaking vote in the Senate
meaning Democrats could have a net gain
of three that would make it 50/50 and
then the vice president who would
presumably be a Democrat if Donald Trump
is defeated would become the
tie-breaking vote in the Senate that's
another scenario so first things first
before we look at what seats Democrats
could take from Republicans are there
any current Democratic seats that could
be lost or are likely to be lost to
Republicans and the answer is yes there
are the one that comes to mind is doug
jones in alabama right now this one is
likely to be lost to a Republican
duck Jones defeated Roy Moore the serial
accused child sex assault her in a
special election down in Alabama at the
end of 2017 if indeed Doug Jones is
defeated and he could win but the
polling doesn't look good for Doug
that would mean Democrats need to take
back five seats in order to net a gain
of four or 4 plus winning the White
House to have the tiebreaker so are
there four or five seats that Democrats
could take from Republicans and the
answer is that yes they are in no
particular order Colorado Colorado is
currently held by Republican Cory
Gardner we have former presidential
candidate Hickenlooper John Hickenlooper
who's running there he's up according to
the latest poll I found by 13 points
that's one seat that is likely to go
from Republicans to Democrats seat
number two this is one of the ones
that's changed recently Susan Collins
because I believe at least partially
hurt loud support for Supreme Court
justice Brett Kavanaugh Susan Collins in
Maine could be defeated now she is
losing popularity she's still doing well
in the Senate polls but she could lose
this is one where the ground game is
what will determine what happens but
it's potentially winnable and it's more
winnable than it's been in a long time
Susan Collins has been in that seat
since 1997 that's 22 years and this is
probably her most vulnerable re-election
campaign yet that would be seat number
two number three Arizona there's that
special election in Arizona for John
McCain see martha mcsalley was appointed
there she has not won an election
astronaut Mark Kelly is running against
her in a recent poll Mark Kelly is plus
two over martha mcsalley the prior poll
had him even it's close but he's in it
that would be seat number three number
four now we're getting a little more
speculative Tom tilling in North
Carolina this is day I'm sorry Tillis
this is definitely one that is a bit
more of a stretch the polling still has
Tillis ahead by about three but he's not
super popular and
North Carolina is a place where we have
seen Republicans move away from
approving of the job that Trump is doing
more than in many other places which
means that it could be winnable in North
Carolina that's four seats and then
number five is Iowa absolute total
lunatic Republican Joni Ernst is still
polling plus two or three in Iowa her
popularity is down significantly she's
cuckoo for cocoa puffs and it is also
potentially winnable so those are the
five homey Alec's seven on our subreddit
also points out there are some longer
shots like if you look at Georgia where
the Republican is only plus five you
could look at Texas John Cornyn is not
super popular I've said what if meadow
O'Rourke were to abandon the race for
the presidential nomination because he
has no chance and get down to Texas
could he defeat John Cornyn so those are
a little more speculative but this is
potentially winnable in 2020 now to be
thorough there's one other democratic
seat that is not super safe and that's
jeanne Shaheen in New Hampshire the
polling is very close we've got to work
on that one as well we have to hope that
the incumbent Democrat will ultimately
ultimately pull away so these races
require work and the important thing to
now if we one do a more macro analysis
this is looking at it race by race the
reality is that the general pro or anti
Trump sentiment pro or anti Republican
sentiment is likely to have a more
general effect so it's not you know if
Texas ends up being in play it's
probable that North Carolina is winnable
and Iowa is winnable etc if Trump's
popularity goes back up if Republican
attitudes towards Republican incumbents
research then it's likely a lot of these
will not go our way but still if you
want to get involved in an individual
race all you can do is work that race
and if you live in any of these states
even if you don't and you can still
phone bank this one's going to require
work but 2020
the Senate is winnable